le 93 le département le plus jeune et
celui qui a eu le plus de surmortalité
pourquoi parce que c'est la population
qui était le plus exposé pourquoi il
était le plus exposé parce que c'était
la population qui travaillait c'est la
population qui était représenté dans le
secteur médical qui étaient représentées
dans le personnel déçu des supermarchés
c'est aussi une population qui vit dans
des logements plus insalubres enquêtant
sur population par rapport au logement
et donc le virus a beaucoup plus
transmis et donc on s'est rendu compte
que finalement les inégalités et ça
s'est vérifié aussi dans d'autres pays
que les inégalités tué et rendrait les
populations plus vulnérables face aux
coronavirus alors que coronavirus frappe
essentiellement des personnes plutôt
âgées au départ donc moi je dirais que
les 40 années ont été vraiment un coup
très fort porté avec l'austérité la
financiarisation et la mondialisation
aux classes populaires et donc ces gens
là sont devenus des meubles aujourd'hui
que l'on ajuste finalement en fonction
des besoins du du patronat ou d un pour
cent des actionnaires et ainsi de suite
qu'on a juste pour que ces gens puissent
garder toujours leur leur part de profit
ou leurs dividendes et les autres on les
bouge en fonction de la conjoncture et
c'est ce qui se passe et ce qui est
dingue c'est que là dessus sur et je
regarde la dernière crise de 2008 et sur
la dernière crise 2008
il ya des tonnes d'argent public qui ont
été sauvés les banques des tonnes
d'agents publics qui ont soutenu
l'activité et on a fait croire aux
populations qu'il avait vécu au dessus
de leurs moyens depuis beaucoup d'années
et c'est là dessus que le patronat a
réussi à négocier des doigts travail et
que le 1% les plus riches a réussi à
baisser sa fiscalité
on a quand même donné ces dernières
années 4 milliards au 1% les plus riches
qui détient déjà 25% du patrimoine donc
voyez et quand on gagne c'est 4
milliards qu'est ce qu'on fait en coupe
de l'autre côté dans les services
publics et le service public c'est quoi
c'est le patrimoine du pauvre donc ce
que l'on donne à des gens quand il ya
une baisse de visiter ce qu'on donne à
certains mais bon on leur prend toujours
de l'autre côté
[Musique]